foreign
[Music]
hi
I'm Mariana how are you doing fantastic
how many people are you expecting to
come tonight you have a phone full of
messages yes tons of them 50 messages
[Music]
and everyone there they're trying to buy
drugs from you I double in a lot of
different communities the freaks come
out tonight
this is Mike a meth dealer from Austin
he tells me he's been dealing meth for
more than five years he doesn't like his
clients knowing where he lives hey girl
so he posts up at a hotel for what he
refers to as a cattle call so who's
coming up now Mr Pink
after some convincing Mike allows us to
watch as he conducts deals on a very
busy Friday night
so can I get with uh to a tree where the
front you want some Crystal mouth yes
okay
thank you
so there comes
it seems like every deal is interrupted
by another call from another customer
the last time meth was this popular Mike
was in elementary school
it's called Crank Crystal or speed
Federal officials say more than 12
million Americans have tried it once you
get that high you just want more and
more and more in the late 90s and early
2000s a new type of drug epidemic began
playing out on local news stations
across the country this is the results
of a meth lab exploding when they
weren't killing themselves amateur
chemists were cooking meth from a toxic
mix of household chemicals and
over-the-counter cold medicine it was a
DIY phenomena that produced one of the
most addictive drugs ever seen
and one of the best TV series ever made
this is Art Mr White
actually it's just basic chemistry but
thank you Jesse I'm glad it's acceptable
it was an epidemic that was devastating
rural White America
perhaps the most lasting images from
those days were put together by a
sheriff's deputy in Oregon
series of before and after mugshots of
users that became known simply as the
Faces of Meth
foreign
but as I talked to some of Mike's
clients in Austin they surprise me I try
to keep a semi like together appearance
I don't look like somebody from pieces
of math and your mom I am
not in a million years would I think
that you use man well I appreciate that
I think because I think there is a
certain stigma that we're all like
Toothless and eating people when we
don't sleep for 10 days
I have an education and I have a job
you're a lawyer yes ISO cars actually
you're able to function and hold a job
yes
I was an interior designer and a very
affluent part of town and you're able to
work yeah how often do you use math
and why do you use it
that's all I'd want to do this is what I
do
[Music]
the demographics of meth users may have
changed but the control the drug asserts
over those users has not
it comes from the power of dopamine math
unleashes a concentrated High to the
pleasure sensors of the brain
and explains why it's so easy for users
of any background to become addictive
how do you do it I inject it is that a
more dangerous way of doing it or more
powerful it's more addictive I would say
it's not even a decision it's like a
loop you just can't get off of you just
reach for it I've basically learned how
to be a high functioning addict
Mike is an addict too
when he's not dealing he's often using
his relationship with meth has been a
roller coaster
I had three houses two cars and lost it
all homeless on the streets four years
have you done time in prison I have
three felonies four drugs possession if
I catch another one I'm gone
it's a license
I made a promise to my mother that would
be here to take care of her and I'm
going to keep that
Mike and his clients are some of the new
faces of meth
I want to understand why meth is making
such a comeback and where it's all
coming from
[Music]
thank you